hi I'm Jeff Croom the security guy of  course for those following this channel  you know that I'm not but if this has  been a real deal fake you might not have  been able to tell the difference what's  a deep fake it's AI manipulated audio  and video so that it looks like someone  is saying something they never actually  said  we use AI in order to determine what  security problems are identify the  source of the problem and even diagnose  and recommend recovery actions but in a  case of adversarial AI the artificial  intelligence is used back against us an  example might be if we create  manipulated video of a CEO saying that  the company is about to go bankrupt  release that on social media and by the  time everyone figures out it's a fake  the stock market has already crashed